Katy Perry and Orlando Bloom have their  eyes on the White House it may be early  to call the upcoming election but we  think Katy and Orlando one Halloween  with their costumes the couple in their  squad stepped out for Kate Hudson's  Halloween party in La Friday night  dressed as Donald Trump and Hillary and  Bill Clinton the roar singer nailed her  look as the Democratic presidential  candidate dressed in an Allred suit  earlier in the night she instagrammed  this shot in full prosthetics and a wig  captioned having a little pre-party  before I take office hashtag I'm with me  her beau Orlando had an even better  disguise at first glance we thought for  sure the actor opted for a Bill Clinton  costume but if you look closely at the  wrist tattoo on the Donald Trump  character it appears to be Orlando  underneath kidding right Haiti and  Orlando seem to opt for less traditional  couples costumes but nonetheless these  two are in the running for best  Halloween costumes of 2016  you